damn that's not great that's a mistake
[Music]
hi my name is alana glazer and i'm here
to react
to some bad mom stories
[Music]
oh god that is so
scary that's actually reminding me of my
horror movie
false positive that's scary that is
scary
and i get it like right now i'm like
it's 20 20
one yeah i get it you're you think it's
like three years ago on your kids
i wouldn't say that's a bad mom i would
say that mom needs
a weekend off and needs to sleep like 36
hours total
[Music]
[Applause]
okay i mean i would feel bad
too maybe you didn't want to deal with
it okay maybe you wanted a weekend
before you spent eight hours in urging
care and
i'm sure the risk didn't dissolve into
nothing
you know what i mean over that time it's
like maybe
it had time to assess the situation
and then by monday you all decided child
mother risked
uh what needed to be done that sucks i
mean it's not great
it's not great
massaging that spot that's damn that's
not great
that's a mistake i hope
also i'm just like you're sending a
three-year-old to go get water that's
like he's an
eight-year-old three-year-old
yikes lol though to drink tequila
that's really funny
oh [ __ ] i actually needed to hear that
for my own i i agree i guess that's the
thing
you shouldn't just rag on people in
front of your kids but i kind of like it
and i like
letting a kid into that kind of i guess
it's not good
[Music]
that's not a bad mom that's an awesome
kid that's hysterical love her love that
kid
[Music]
i mean i'm like that's dope this this is
bad moms we should say this is like
self partially judging moms i'm loving
all these stories
i love a kid dancing to jlo
like mimicking jlo that's i think that's
power
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever